quand j'ai débuté la chlorophylle et
donc j'ai acheté à un poisson qui
s'appelle un bottier hamac racontars et
ce poisson gp à 23 ans je l'aï acheté il
a encore la une où à 27° quelques
rochers pour se cacher et une nourriture
riche paye tous n'ont que ce poisson se
plaisent ici dans la nature son
espérance de vie est estimée entre 10 et
20 ans quand on a pour le progrès c'est
qu'on arrive à garder les poissons plus
longtemps qu'il vivrait dans la nature
là on a rejoint l'objectif principal
c'est de recréer un environnement vidéo
pour cent pour les poissons qu'on
accueille eric est ce qu'on appelle un
aquariophile un passionné de l'univers
aquatique
cela fait 18 ans qu'il a rejoint le club
d'aquariophilie de guyancourt
comme lui ils sont une dizaine à se
retrouver tous les samedis pour partager
leurs connaissances
concrètement il ya de l'entretien déjà
au niveau tout ce qui est filtration les
vitres des aquariums et puis au niveau
de la reproduction il ya certain nombre
qui s'en occupe parce qu'en ce moment on
a beaucoup de poissons des lacs des lacs
d'afrique par exemple là on en a deux
du lac de malawi donc la c1 après grands
lacs africains et on a des beaux
trophées musée bras ça peut être dans
l'amazonie on a différents biotopes
qu'on essaie de reproduire justement
objectifs du club
essayer de rentrer en bourse aux
poissons avec leur propre élevage un
loisir qui se veut avant tout apaisant
ou le bien-être des animaux est le plus
important
mais avant de les introduire dans leur
nouvel environnement en fait il faut les
acclimater
quand on appelle ça voilà une
acclimatation donc ça consiste en fait à
les habituer à l'autre du nouvel
aquarium
pourquoi qui est un trop grand choc par
rapport à l'eau il était juste avant
donc chez moi chacun est invité à
rejoindre le club à condition d'être
majeur spécialistes et débutants
pourront s'y sentir comme des poissons
dans l'eau